hi guys Lucy here with the rather
aromatic gamespot news update for you
Microsoft is set to compete against the
gods of fragrance by launching their own
scent it's a cheeky floral number that
symbolizes glamour sophistication and a
little bit of competitive jealousy
destiny the new fragrance by xbox I'm
not even joking about this this picture
was linked to buy an official Xbox UK
Twitter account but what does it smell
like hmm smells like bull reason being
is that the Jolly Green Giant isn't
really dipping its toes into musky
cologne manufacturing waters but what's
with the bizarre tweet well if you head
to destiny fragrance calm the mystery
unravels pretty quickly you see in the
UK at least Microsoft isn't allowed to
run adverts for destiny on the Xbox one
due to an agreement between Activision
and Sony clicking through the website
and message appears saying okay so
here's the lowdown destiny is actually
an epic new first person shooter
available on xbox thing is we didn't
have permission to run adverts for the
game so we didn't thanks for smelling
that something was up now get the game
and become a legend the website then
shows you a few links where you can buy
an xbox one bundled with destiny such a
restriction caused quite a stink sorry
I'm not sorry within Microsoft marketing
department and quite clearly has brought
out the perfumers among the team destiny
launches on sep tember the 9th on xbox
360 xbox one and I think it's available
on other platforms as well something
like PlayStation I don't know so what
did you do work today Lucy well
something I never thought I'd do that's
what are you going to get destiny on the
odor Xbox or for the PlayStation perfume
what is destiny even smell like let me
know in the comments for all the latest
gaming odors stay tuned here at gamespot
you